it is exceptionally difficult to make a
video on a divisive subject when it
is so fresh for me as a content creator
i know that there's
absolutely no way on earth this video
will be unanimously enjoyed regardless
of what i say there will be someone who
takes issue with it that's
true of any kind of review but with
something so fresh
in this case attack on titan's ending
emotions are still
very high and people are incredibly
vocal unwilling to let go of those
initial feelings to approach the subject
with nuance
this is both understandable and a little
frustrating frustrating because it
actually masks what the general
consensus is
angry people are both loud and
relentless and it can often take many
months for things to quiet down and for
the larger picture to emerge
one of the most recent examples of this
is the video game the last of us too
prior to launch spotty leaks lacking the
greater context of the story emerged
leading to an early feeling of anger
from certain parts of the gaming
community the game launched and those
people got louder and louder and if you
were to engage with discussion around
that game within the first few weeks
or simply consumed nothing but
hyperbolic or disingenuous memes
you might get the impression that the
game was an irredeemable failure from
start to finish
of course you look at things nowadays
with the unsavory parts of the fandom
largely ignored and
the situation's a lot more nuanced than
that which might have been apparent
it has broken sales records garnered
universal critical praise
and continued to win countless awards
many of which were voted on by
fans gamers vocally praised it across
social media and while there are
absolutely those with incredibly strong
negative opinions concerning it of which
they are entirely valid and failing
the general response to the game is so
much more balanced and nuanced nowadays
now that might sound like a somewhat
strange tangent but really
it's a roundabout way of me trying to
say the intensely negative reactions to
attack on titan's ending that are
circulating the internet right now
may not necessarily reflect how the
greater population feels as a whole
or it could be like game of thrones
where everyone under the sun despises
the ending and the whole thing is
entirely soured
you are my queen
nothing will change though we'll see i
guess but as it currently stands
attack on titan's ending is one of
immense magnitude it is dense
nuanced symbolic it is one with
tremendous thematic impact and filled to
the brim with tragic uncertainty
and yet it is likewise clumsy rushed and
borderline juvenile at times
you may sit either side of the fence or
you may be somewhere in the middle but
either way i hope you'll take the time
to consider my perspective
as i will yours and maybe together we'll
gain a greater understanding of what
this conclusion
11 years in the making truly offers
this is attack on titan's highly
controversial final chapter
toward the tree on that hill
[Music]
for dozens upon dozens of chapters
readers of attack on titan have been
privy to a version of aaron yeager that
spawned from
years of suffering a child forced and
tragedy who began to sink deeper and
deeper into darkness
longing for freedom convinced of the
world's irredeemable
nature he became a character that
readers understood wholeheartedly
deeply empathized with but ultimately
and very reasonably
considered to be in the wrong standing
strong with the likes of armin and his
cohorts the notion that violence begets
more violence has been a long-standing
mantra for readers of this franchise
this final chapter however
recontextualizes everything we've ever
seen
while simultaneously maintaining the
very high tragedy we all fell in love
with in the first place
in a lengthy conversation between aaron
and armin we come to understand the
truth of erin yeager's tragedy
one of immeasurable weight and
heartbreak we come to learn that upon
touching historia's hand at the awards
ceremony at the end of season three
aaron gained total omniscience the power
to see
everything that is was and will be he
gained a full understanding of the
world's face along with emir's memories
and emotions and
all that her powers entail and with that
came a horrific curse
he saw the endless possibilities the
inevitable outcomes and
after exploring each and every path he
came to understand that
there was but one singular path he must
keep pushing towards
if he were to ever achieve his goal for
those of you who are intimately familiar
with the marvel cinematic universe
this shouldn't be a new concept in
avengers infinity war doctor strange
looks into the future at the millions of
possible outcomes in their predicament
with thanos
and discovers that there's a singular
outcome in which they prevail
this is fundamentally the same concept
in attack on titan though
steeped in its unrelentingly oppressive
world
while we as readers had previously come
to believe aaron's unjust actions were
the result of his internal logic twisted
by his harrowed surroundings
this revelation recontextualizes aaron's
motives instead spitting a tale of a man
cursed with knowledge forced to
ostracize himself and turn against
everyone he ever loved or cared about in
the pursuit of freedom
freedom for his friends and freedom for
his people perhaps the most tragic
action unveiled here is the
understanding that aaron
caused the death of his own mother in
chapter 96 of the manga we see that the
titan dina
encroaches upon berthold and yet she
walks straight past him
40 chapters later we come to understand
that it was aaron who saved bertol's
life here in this instance
honestly it's a concept that's hard to
comprehend and these types of time
manipulation stories are never
easy unfortunately but i'll do my best
to explain it to the best of my
understanding and
hopefully it's largely correct within
the paths all
events occur on a fixed timeline and
everything happens in the same
instant this is why airing can still
affect things that have already happened
since he is perceiving everything all at
the same time
likewise in terms of the predetermined
fates mentioned in this chapter
aaron's mother will always die and
bertholt will always die
and there's no way to change that this
is evident in chapter 131 where although
aaron saves the young boy ramsay from
being murdered by street thugs he
acknowledges the pointlessness
of his actions as the boy will still
ultimately die later via the rumbling
what's important to understand however
is that things can be delayed and
shifted around or manipulated to an
extent
this is seen in aaron's manipulation of
grecia to take the founding titan for
example
what's tragic in this reveal here
however is that
the way in which aaron's mother died had
to be this way
for it to serve as aaron's motivator and
berthold's death as a result had to be
prolonged for this part of the story to
play out in a way that leads to the
ideal outcome aaron is pushing towards
that outcome being his death at the
hands of a very
special person all alone aaron could do
nothing but ensure the wheels of fate
kept turning to the exact specification
required to hit the outcome
of freedom and so to put it as simply as
possible aaron is looking down at a
great puzzle capable of forming many
pictures but only one specific
combination of those puzzle pieces will
produce
the picture aaron is seeking and that
picture is
freedom aaron continues to issue his
reasoning and armin
explaining the crux of his dilemma
emir's inescapable connection to king
fritz
abused from her very birth yamir's life
has been one of
never-ending ill treatment and
exploitation not once has she
experienced normality and in spite of
the horrific acts enacted on her by the
king
her understanding of love never wavered
her resolve
worn away and beaten down yamir is left
incapable of fathoming a world where she
does not obey her abuser
and so she continues to maintain the
existence of titans in the world
prolonging the curse of her people which
means for this tragic cycle to end
for these chains of fate to ultimately
break aaron must follow along on the
singular path he witnessed
that leads to salvation the key to the
lock on that chain is none other than
mikasa ymir so desperate to be released
from the agony of her love
found a sort of indirect kinship in
mikasa throughout this story mikasa's
love for aaron has been so strong to the
point that she actively values him over
everything else even her own life as
armin so succinctly pointed out
isiama even goes as far as to create a
direct parallel with king fritz saying
to amir
in an earlier chapter emir my slave
and aaron repeating to mikasa in their
confrontation
you're a slave mikasa both shackled
slaves to love
emir's choice in mikasa is both
understandable and pivotal in the events
that follow
as amir watches mikasa's actions over
the course of the narrative her
understanding of their shared
perspective on love grows stronger and
in those final moments as mikusa cast
aside her love for aaron to do the right
thing in putting him to death
behind her stands none other than emir a
smile on her face as she realizes that
if mikasa could shed her love for the
greater good
then perhaps she could too and that is
precisely what she does
eradicating the titans and setting the
aldians free and
when relayed like this i find that
attack on titan's resolution is
remarkably powerful
building upon years of strong thematic
character writing all coming to a head
wrapping up in exceptionally tragic lore
unfortunately
the clarity of this narrative both in
its dialogue quality
and presentation of events is where this
final chapter falls flat and it's where
i imagine a great deal of the online
animosity stems from
marge i'm confused is this a happy
ending or a sad ending
it's an ending that's enough despite the
chapter's rather lengthy 50 pages
only 20 of those are dedicated to the
content i've outlined thus far
with the remainder delegated to short
snippets of character moments and
details of the finale's aftermath while
those remaining 30 pages are to me the
strongest parts of the chapter
it's those initial 20 that serve as the
resolution to aaron's character arc and
the greater conflict that the series has
hinged on
since its inception for such important
subjects to be crammed into such a
short amount of time is incredibly
disconcerting and where i believe the
biggest flaws of this ending stem from
when dealing with complex subjects it's
vital to speak plainly and to present
your views with plot threads that can be
tied together naturally while reading
that's not to say media can't be
challenging thought-provoking or
require multiple viewings to truly grasp
but the emotional impact of a piece of
media is greatly diminished if the
majority of your audience is focused on
the logistics behind your story's
mechanics
then living the emotions of the scene
along with the characters
and so contained with only 20 pages much
of the expository dialogue here feels
remarkably brief and undercooked
and as a result arma's reactions begin
to feel the same way the structure
largely
features armin relaying the basics of
what's happening with aaron dropping
large plot bombs and not really
elaborating on them further it's
important to give audiences time to
breathe
take in major plot points and assess
them in the greater context of the story
but
that's not what happens here readers
have barely had a chance to ingest the
reveal of emir stockholm syndrome before
aaron reveals mikis's importance one
page later there's a single page to
breathe before the exceedingly complex
concept of time is dropped on us which
is then followed up by the reveal
regarding aaron's mother
a second later and characters are having
big emotional outbursts and
none of that works because justifiably
readers cannot be invested in the
emotion of a scene if they're still busy
processing the prior points aaron has
this moment of total fragility as he
breaks on the subject of mikusa
heartbroken over his fate to never be
with her he wants to feel his presence
is still in the world long after he's
gone particularly in mikis mind the
person who's been his number one since
the story's beginnings
the concept behind this scene is largely
not an issue but the way it's placed
in this chapter and given no surrounding
context is
with no real lead in or lead out to
bring readers back around to this
version of aaron
the outburst feels quite silly and
juvenile when its intent is to be
heartbreaking it's the same issue that
plagues many of armin's reactions here
particularly the famous lion where he
thanks aaron for becoming a
mass murderer for the sake of their
future and okay
while i do feel that in general the way
that that line is phrased is quite bad
the intent behind it is powerful having
come to understand the horrific
sacrifices made
armin once driven by dialogue over
violence finally understands the truth
of aaron's actions and
thanks him for enduring his cursed
destiny it's a reconciliation between
two friends that have drifted apart but
it just doesn't land and it should
with neither of them addressing the
residual faults in each other
it all feels a bit hollow and
understandably you have readers asking
why a b
and c were never addressed now i'm not
going to sit here and try to dictate to
you all how i feel the chapter should
have been written point by point i mean
i think isayam has proven his competency
over the past 11 years and
suggesting that i could do better would
be immensely disrespectful but
i don't think it'd be particularly
unfair to say that this chapter could
have benefited from being split into two
40 to 50 pages dedicated to the
explanation of events
a version that features a nuanced
buildup of these complex emotions
changing as aaron transparently
elaborates on his torturous time
throughout the series
a version that allows digestion time and
breathing room and allows these morally
complex themes to be explored in ways
that best
fit the characters involved those
initial 20 pages are exclusively where
my major issues with this ending lie and
the remainder at least to me are almost
perfect
containing the most significant
emotional payoffs of the series
fulfilling themes in the making
for all these years returning to their
human forms the victims of these
previous chapters
regain their memories coming to
understand aaron's intentions in the
same way readers just witnessed
armin doing it's a powerful moment
particularly with the likes of annie and
reiner finally reuniting with their
families
this time with a hug and a lot less
tragedy heck falco and gabby's reunion
is so powerful that she straight up
suplexes him with no remorse
alas however the surface level happiness
is underpinned with pain
and sorrow and that's a running theme
for this ending
against the background of these happy
reunions is a farewell as armani mikasa
mourned the loss of aaron
and discuss the best place to honor his
memory far away from those who'd
interfere with a proper send-off
likewise in what is perhaps the most
emotionally resonant moment in this
final chapter
levi connie and john reflect on the
symbolic visions of their lost comrades
allowing themselves one last farewell
dozens upon
dozens of lost lives all leading to this
outcome
and levi left permanently scarred
he wistfully utters i guess this is the
result of
all of your devoted hearts the mantra of
the survey core
issued one last time against the
backdrop of human sacrifice
it's one of the most beautifully
bittersweet moments of this series and
i can't help but feel emotional just
relaying it to you all right now
one last synchronized fist to the heart
as the fallen heroes of his story
vanish into the mist of the aftermath
leaving behind a shadow
of the wings of freedom and it's that
sense of freedom that resonates
throughout the remaining pages of this
story whether the marlians truly trust
that the titan threat is gone
is left ambiguous and ultimately that's
the point
they're allowed to live and for the
first time they're given a chance
at life for many fans the reveal that
the identity of historia's child's
father was a red herring
has been a source of major
disappointment and while i can't
understand that to an extent
i think the purpose of that child has
been sorely misunderstood
for me turning the page to reveal a
three-year time skip against the
backdrop of an ldn child celebrating her
third birthday
in total normality was such a
thematically powerful reveal
that any misgivings of being misled
simply vanished
a sign of fearless normality in a warlik
attack on titan sends a powerful message
to readers about the success of aaron's
actions
and page by page the remaining panels
dictate the state of the world
three years after the climactic battle
and this is where the nuances of the
story most clearly come to light
after all the struggles aaron went
through all the pain the suffering and
the death
war continues to rumble across the land
so
what was aaron really fighting for it's
here that i think the obvious parallels
to watchmen's dr manhattan are
important to consider much like aaron dr
manhattan has an omniscient sense of
time
and one of his most famous quotes is i
can change
almost anything but i can't change human
nature and i think that notion is
incredibly
pertinent to aaron's actions within the
story war has
always and will always be a thing human
nature's sense of tribalism is deeply
ingrained and that's not going away
any time soon but that was never aaron's
goal he was never trying to
tie a neat bow on the world's issues and
vanished into the sunset as the sole
savior of the world
aaron's primary concern has always been
about freedom and that's precisely what
he provided for his people
the aldeans the people of paradise
they're on a level playing field with
the remainder of the world now after
centuries of being perceived as monsters
they're beginning to be seen as
people the titans once a horrifying tool
for the apocalypse used to frighten the
other nations are
now gone for good these people are free
from the recurring fate of suffering and
now stand on equal footing using their
traumatic story to underpin the campaign
for peace
in the world mass genocide happened it's
a thing and it will need to be
acknowledged and
while armies are built by those in fear
of retaliation
there now exists a worldwide curiosity
about the people of paradise's message
of peace
a message of freedom and that's
precisely what makes the final pages of
this story so powerful
as mikasa sits by aaron's grave longing
to see him again
a bird appears tugging at her scarf and
wrapping it over her shoulder
throughout the series the wings of a
bird have been a symbol for freedom the
hope for all mankind and for aaron to
appear symbolically in this way and
hearken back to the comfort he provides
mikasa and now all of mankind
that is one heck of a powerfully
resonant final image to leave the series
on
taking all of that into consideration
unfortunately thematic consistency can
only take quality so far when the
presentation of these aspects
is such a mixed bag and sadly that
remains the chapter's biggest flaw it's
something i think is worth thinking
about though it's easier to make fun of
something than to try and understand it
and
i think people in time as the
conversation online becomes more honest
we may all arrive at similar conclusions
that attack on titan's ending
isn't game of thrones it isn't throwing
away years of transparent character arcs
ignoring unfinished plot threads and
bending over backwards to justify its
conclusions
the final chapter is obtuse underbaked
and rushed
but what it isn't is a betrayal of its
legacy
a legacy that reminds us that the ashes
of destruction can stand for more than
sorrow they can mark the birthplace of a
new era one
of reflection and new opportunity
through all the suffering comes eventual
relief
and the potential for change it's a
message that resonates in many aspects
of life both within the pages of this
manga
and the real world and while i so wish
that this ending had more room to
breathe to say what it wanted to say
with perfect clarity
i can't say it was a failure and with
all said and done
i still love attack on titan
thanks for watching guys last week's
video was one of the most challenging
projects i've ever attempted in the
history of my channel and i'd like to
once again extend a special thank you to
all of my patreon supporters for their
unwavering support
and specifically to anime aj for writing
this week's video
so that i could sleep this week in
addition to that one name i neglected to
shout out last week was a fantastic
channel by the name of literal maverick
his analysis of the political
controversy surrounding the series
proved to be
invaluable when creating that particular
section in my previous video and he's a
great guy so
please check out his channel but now
that i've completed attack on titan in
the truest sense of the word
it's time for my next big adventure
next week i'm diving headfirst into one
of the most beloved and troubled series
in japan
next week i'm starting the legendary
hunter hunter
[Music]
you